S&P 500 LOST 13 ON THE NASDAQ
WAS DOWN JUST A LITTLE MORE THAN
48.
CHICAGO POLICE TODAY FIRE BACK
AT PROSECUTORS WHO DROPPED
CHARGES AGAINST ACTOR JUSSIE
SMOLLETT THIS AFTERNOON,
RELEASING PAGES OF EVIDENCE THAT
LED TO THE ORIGINAL 16 CHARGES
AGAINST SMOLLETT.
MATT FINN WITH A LOOK AT THE
EVIDENCE IN THE ONGOING FURY
OVER THE SURPRISE DISMISSAL OF
CHARGES.
>> TODAY CHICAGO POLICE RELEASED
SOME OF ITS JUSSIE SMOLLETT
FILES BEFORE THE CASE WAS
SEALED, DOCUMENTS READ THAT THE
OSUNDAIRO BROTHERS CLAIMED THEY
DIDN'T SEND THE DEATH THREAT
LETTER THAT POLICE ALLEGED
SMOLLETT INTO HIMSELF.
POLICE SAY THE FBI'S
INVESTIGATING THE LETTER.
TODAY COOK COUNTY STATES
ATTORNEY KIM FOXX WHO RECUSED
HERSELF DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE
SMOLLETT INVESTIGATION SAID
SMOLLETT LIKELY WOULD NOT HAVE
GONE TO PRISON, AS HE'S A
NONVIOLENT OFFENDER WHO
FORFEITED HIS $10,000 BOND AND
DID COMMUNITY SERVICE.
IN A RADIO INTERVIEW, FOXX SAYS
I THINK THE CONFUSION FOR PEOPLE
WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
INTRICACIES OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM, WHO DON'T UNDERSTAND
ALTERNATIVE PROSECUTION, IT'S A
HARD THING FOR PEOPLE TO
PROCESS.
FOX NEWS OBTAINED A COPY OF AN
INTERNAL EMAIL FROM KIM FOXX'S
OFFICE REQUESTING EXAMPLES OF
OTHER CASES TO BOLSTER ITS
STANCE THAT DROPPED CHARGES ARE
NOT UNCOMMON.
THE EMAIL READS "NOBODY IS IN
TROUBLE.
WE ARE JUST LOOKING FOR FURTHER
EXAMPLES OF HOW WE AS
PROSECUTORS USE OUR DISCUSSION
IN A WAY THAT RESTORES THE
VICTIM BUT DOES MINIMAL HARM TO
THE DEFENDANT."
OTHER MESSAGES REVEAL
MICHELLE OBAMA'S FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF TINA TCHEN PERSUADED FOXX
TO ASK THE CHICAGO POLICE
SUPERINTENDENT TO TURN THE
INVESTIGATION OVER TO THE FBI
BECAUSE THE SMOLLETT FAMILY WAS
WORRIED ABOUT LEAKS.
"I WANTED TO GIVE YOU A CALL ON
BEHALF OF JUSSIE SMOLLETT AND
FAMILY WHO I KNOW.
THEY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION."
FOXX RESPONDED, SPOKE TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT JOHNSON, I
CONVINCED HIM TO REACH OUT TO
THE FBI TO ASK THAT THEY TAKE
OVER THE INVESTIGATION.
HE IS REACHING OUT NOW I WILL
GET TO ME SHORTLY."
THE ATTORNEY FOR THE OSUNDAIRO
BROTHERS SAY THAT THEY WERE
READY TO TESTIFY BEFORE THE CASE
WAS DROPPED.
FOX NEWS CAUGHT UP WITH THE
BROTHERS AT AN EVENT.
>> YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF FANS IN
CHICAGO.
WHAT HAVE YOU GOT TO SAY TO YOUR
FANS?
>> THE CHICAGO POLICE UNION HAS
REQUESTED THE U.S. ATTORNEY'S